إن نظرية المؤامرة التي تمزق
السياسات الجمهورية والتي
يشارك أتباعها في الهجوم على العاصمة
هي موضوع تقرير خاص جديد لشبكة سي
إن إن كنا نعمل
عليه ، يطلق عليه داخل مؤامرة qa التي
تبث غدًا
تتبع بدايات الحركة.
خلال اللحظة الحالية ، إنه أيضًا
شيء من مشروع شخصي
، فقد ركزت عليه هامش q9 سابقًا
علي ومجموعة من المراسلين الآخرين
بالإضافة إلى العديد من الشخصيات العامة الأخرى
باعتبارها مسؤولة بطريقة ما عن بعض
من أكثرها غرابة إذا قلنا
ومؤامرات غريبة
كنت  يُطلق عليه أيضًا اسم
سجلات رحلات الطيران الوهمية التي يُزعم أنها من
مرتكب جريمة جنسية مدان ،
ظهرت على الإنترنت باسمي وعشرات
الأشخاص الآخرين المعروفين ،
يبدو أن جميع
المؤيدين يعتقدون ذلك
أو على الأقل يستخدمونه لمحاولة
لمضايقتي ،
كان shitarth jadeja مؤمنًا حتى يونيو 2019.
هل كنت تعتقد في ذلك الوقت أن
الديمقراطيين رفيعي المستوى
كان المشاهير يعبدون الشيطان وهو يشرب
دماء الأطفال
أندرسون ، اعتقدت أنك فعلت ذلك
وأود أن أعتذر عن
ذلك الآن ، لذا أعتذر عن
التفكير في أنك أكلت
أطفالًا ولكنك في الحقيقة مائة بالمائة لكنك في الواقع
تؤمن  أنني كنت أشرب دماء
الأطفال ،
نعم فعلت ، هل كان شيئًا
يخصني جعلك تعتقد أن
السبب هو أن q ذكرك على
وجه التحديد وذكرك في وقت مبكر جدًا ، لقد ذكرك بالاسم
ومن هناك إذا تحدث أيضًا عن
مثل من أجل  مثال مثل عائلتك ولكن
نعم
وأنا سأكون صادقًا مثل الناس
ما زالوا يتحدثون عن ذلك حتى يومنا هذا
. كانت هناك منشورات حول ذلك
منذ أربعة أيام فقط
لذا اعتقد بعض الناس أنك كنت روبوتًا
كنت تعتقد حقًا
هذا  لم أصدق أنني
اعتقدت في مرحلة ما أن
أه كان جزءًا من
المخابرات العسكرية وهو ما يقوله
ولكن علاوة على ذلك ، فإن الأشخاص الذين
يقفون وراءهم كانوا في الواقع رائعون
طائر فضائي ذو قدمين
خارج الأرض
يسمى الطيور الزرقاء ،
كنت بعيدًا جدًا
في هذا الثقب الأسود المؤامرة الذي كنت
أختار وأختار
أي قصة أردت أن
أؤمن بها